concerns that a new 5g service could
pose risks to aircraft instruments has
prompted international airlines to
cancel some u.s bound flights even after
a t and verizon agreed to limit the
signal near u.s airports the pace of
cancellations eased wednesday once it
became clear that the faa would allow
most flights to proceed
airlines have been caught in the middle
of a dispute between the wireless
industry and the federal aviation
administration and executives have
repeatedly raised alarms about what this
could mean for business i think if you
were to ask us what our number one
concern is here in the near term it is
the deployment of 5g
airline executives have warned of
significant flight disruptions after the
faa said it could impose restrictions on
landing aircraft in up to 46 of the
country's largest metropolitan areas
where the service was scheduled to be
rolled out the faa says the new 5g
signals could possibly interfere with
cockpit safety systems but the wireless
industry is pushing back against those
claims here's what you need to know
a bulletin sent by the faa says that 5g
interference could result in erroneous
altimeter readings and loss of altimeter
function
a radar or radio altimeter is a key
piece of equipment that tells a pilot
the plane's altitude it does this by
sending radio waves to the ground that
return to the aircraft radar altimeter
sends signals at narrow frequencies that
wouldn't interfere with the planned 5g
signal but some more sensitive models
could receive signals that come from the
cellular towers
the faa says this has the potential to
produce inaccurate readings if they
can't be relied on because of potential
interference then the regulators are
going to prohibit use of certain cockpit
safety systems that rely on these
devices and that's going to have
significant ripple effects for air
travel airplane manufacturers have also
raised a red flag about 5g's impact on
safety the aerospace
manufacturers are concerned because they
don't want their planes to crash they
have a keen interest in making sure that
airlines can safely operate their
products
the ceos of boeing and airbus americas
sent a letter to transportation
secretary pete butterjudge in december
the executive said 5g interference could
adversely affect the ability of aircraft
to safely operate and that faa
restrictions as a result could have an
enormous negative impact on the aviation
industry but not everyone agrees with
the safety concerns
the federal communications commission
said that the limits it had set on the
cellular service would be enough to
protect air traffic they've got spectrum
experts and engineers that don't see any
risk to aviation safety and ctia a
wireless industry trade group has
responded sharply to the concerns voiced
by the faa and others saying the
aviation industry's fear-mongering
relies on completely discredited
information and deliberate distortions
of fact
the industry group also points to the
frequencies used in nearly 40 countries
and says none has reported any harmful
interference with aviation equipment but
what may work in one country may not
work in another because 5g is rolled out
in a different spectrum or at different
power levels with antennas pointed in
different directions some countries have
imposed buffer zones around airports
it's really not apples to apples
airlines have urged cooperation with the
wireless industry and regulators to
resolve the issue to avoid disruptions
to their operations i do know that the
safety concerns uh with aircraft and
aviation are very real and i also know
that there's a solution here we could
absolutely uh solve this and live in a
world where there is 5g available at t
and verizon had been planning to switch
on the new service on january 5th but
reverse course on january 3rd the
wireless carriers agreed to delay the
rollout by two weeks at the request of
the transportation department the
transportation department and the faa
were essentially asking for more time so
they can figure out how to narrowly
tailor flight restrictions during those
two weeks the faa picked 50 airports
where buffer zones would be implemented
limiting 5g signals for 6 months to help
avoid disruptions from the expected
flight restrictions but verizon and at t
agreed to limit the service even further
saying they will not switch the service
on within two miles of airport runways
aviation safety officials say these
limits will avert many but likely not
all cancellations and delays we are
ready for you to send us a route
revision the faa says it will work with
airplane manufacturers and airlines to
ensure aircraft can safely operate with
the new cell service the agency says it
would ease restrictions as more
altimeters are tested and either deemed
safe retrofitted or replaced
you